hello rejects its Greg Alba here with
the lovely so Howard Twitter FL Howard
what's happening want to accent today
no no you I feel like a win that's my
terrible jobs no aggression and so much
snow no I found out by anyway John so I
have a mixture of terrible impressions
in some decent impressions that's one of
my terrible one I'm still pretty good my
rocky impression I don't go with you
actually I only go to touch my head I
also have a cuddly C please Khaleesi
so I got and that yours called are
Belarusian no it's my Jorah oh okay see
it's a great impression she nailed
ideally I know exactly what he's going
for
anyway Game of Thrones Season 7 trailer
to hash tag winter is finally [__]
here so blood up does alone why talk
anymore about it we all we don't
watching whatever cool [__] careful
we have now they just want to watch the
trains on a lot straighter more watch us
watching will be no opinions after the
trailers but no opinions you just have
your stats anyone will be emotionless
during this yes Phoenix Zoo
South Side every bottle everywhere
always in your mind voice watch
[Music]
damn badass guys very grown-up
centuries our families thought together
against their common enemy
it's like that different today
we do significant spike
the enemy is really
neither have always been me
[Music]
Wow
Jamie and warm
[Music]
it's nice for the white wings blow the
language guys like a packs of ice
ah was that a hint I don't know
that business I don't know worthwhile
video / wait wait I hear that line again
guarantee this is the line everyone's
good selves yeah John my white things
like why lens dies everyone dies the
back survives
I think the pack survives what she's
saying yeah and we're on the same page
here yeah I think that I can't I still
can't understand your accent okay me
target yeah what I can sound like she
was implying that jon snow dies when the
snow falls and the loan was dying well
pack unified yeah the lone wolf dies
John snow being the lone wolf and the
path being the Starks yeah I feel like
that's what she was fighting like the
pack survivor like the starts are the
only ones that are yeah I'm gonna
survive this whole thing because they're
all they've all design off this whole
time everyone else on surviving but [__]
all that winter is finally here this is
their time their time is the only this
is what they've been repairing for the
whole show is the winter it's been
coming now it's here and they're like
fishes I told you okay who do you
think's in to kill Jon Snow I don't know
I don't know if he's gonna die we're
going to miss by it I don't think she
met Jon Snow my lone wolf he already
died I don't know if they're gonna do
that again okay if he dies you should
actually die this night yeah and you
like to kill them all
no more redirecting what this commoner
was saying about how it's not
necessarily the ones gonna die but if
you don't stick together you won't
survive either emotionally or okay so it
might not mean like post like yeah all
snow dies directons that we have to work
together right so I have to be United
yeah even the best of some Jon Snow yes
it is that's I love it I love everyone
in this show called a bastard the same
way yes no matter what character you are
you get that bastard so they can be
having like a normal conversation this
is my last area this is Jon Snow he's a
bastard son of Nestle I think maybe they
threw that
line in there and they show this little
clip of joseline hating someone because
they're trying to get you to think that
maybe John Snow actually dies because we
don't want him to die mm I'm kind of
curious I hope he does end up marrying
his that what's his relationship with
Daenerys now he's a cousin or something
um not sister that's what it is
you know everyone tells me they have a
different relationship have a sister or
that today yeah see it's kind of
confusing so how does this turn in man
wait because oh but I forgot everything
that happened yes it's a lot to keep up
with it I forgot everything happened
they're related in some way it's like a
friend of mr. for almost for sure well I
do
I do hope they end up together something
tells me Littlefinger is going to order
a hit on - no I feel like Littlefinger
will probably become like a major
villain for sure well he's been the
villain the whole time really because he
started everything off he's the one that
sorts of extreme yeah he's a mobster and
he's hoping after he put that hit on the
one assassination and that started
everything that happens I hope Arya
kills him I hope so too I think Arya
would be the one to put a blade right
through this the road yeah yeah I want
her to become the major assassin of the
show I feel like she'll probably end up
that at the top hero in this I wonder if
her The Hound will reconnect they have -
yeah - they're faded I hope she died
hope they like somehow make some type of
because from the last season they kind
of made it seem like the how am I turned
into a better person yeah not so much
about how he survived because she left
him with a broken leg today and then you
know he's like in a village fixing
things yeah he's a hound Oh Hank you are
sure you can survive anything external
to use face
he's like an old um old dog in a
junkyard like they're never dead yeah
you never feel like a dead junkyard dog
they're always like alive but missing
bones hmmm yeah I wasn't even going
there we got a new job
they see you you're you're connected the
duck the head of myself you guys we see
Cersei is I don't know how she's going
to lead you know what I would love I
would love it his Cersei wins in the end
of No oh so entertaining just to see the
audience uproar over seriously winning
in the end all the starting to die the
narrow side the Dragons become loyal to
Cersei know how great here did no no no
no no no I know this we're going to get
plenty of likes now that I said that and
I'm going to get even more subscribers
not lose any by saying that Cersei
should win in the end writers if you
haven't written it out yet
Cersei should win I mean I think Jon
Snow is gonna end up on the throne
because I mean Danny is you know would
be next in line but appease what the
spaces son then he is technically next
in line so then she's his aunt
I'm so confused about what's happening
yeah I saw a whole like family tree
breakdown online and I was still like I
don't think about it I don't forget
about it so much too much every word
that like maybe Tyrion is a Targaryen no
so then that makes him Jon Snow's uncle
or brother to much much keep them a
Lannister why did you want a family and
I never I hadn't read the book scrapbook
too but apparently it's like he has more
white hair in the books they describe
them more as like a Targaryen never
really you show them I don't know if
that's what they're going to do and if
that's why step secretly Maya feminism
it's because not just because like you
don't have to go to the line of this I
don't know I'm thinking was the
Lannisters Tyrion and Jaime might work
together and Jamie might kill Cersei
really I think Jamie might become a good
guy in the end he might realize his
sister's a [__] evil little bit more
girlfriend to have yeah she's cheated on
him plenty of time yeah yeah oh if she's
not with everyone before you slept with
her own for quite the worst sister yeah
that's not worth it yeah she cheats on
your sister she thought only [__] me all
in the family not a yeah not anyone
not man [__] up glad we had that
partner to keep it here keep the echo
because what do you thinks gonna happen
with brand I feel like he's going to
become a white Walker he said Michigan a
warm any one of the Dragons right and
half that's what I think is gonna like
that he's gonna turn into something else
yeah I feel more men went and stay that
way because who wants to say like he
doesn't like a better manager yeah
no he doesn't want to say that way I'm
not saying who want to do like their
body is nothing 80% of our demographic
our triple view really isolating like
really didn't know I feel like that was
that would be what would eventually make
him feel completed that he hasn't felt
like himself since he NSmen he wants to
be a warrior creature
I don't know these are all great
predictions at UNR me yes he's going to
become a war tree shirt series gonna win
in the kitchen and Jon Snow we're gonna
find out is actually gay oh yeah which
is nothing wrong but I think I'd be a
great twist
don't let me great twist like Jon Snow
Daenerys Falls for him but Johnson I was
like I actually like dick actually yeah
I love dick why do you think it's not
working the whole time to come o or what
I love that one with that that's the
same Nami is there a girl a wind it's
all wood oh please please cut that out
because I love all nerd street cred I
got nervous
sorry mortgages or what weight is is
that Harry Potter know where one is
before the reason know would take it all
out cut it all cut it all what's insane
Greenwood great work great work god he
has no wood that's a part of his
character he's a eunuch great
uh is in there gray learned who are you
saying would know as a woman not as a
wood is not in the character II have no
wood pretty well we gray were right get
whatever no dick
grey worm note that's what yes I would
that's not accurate dude ah one wire man
really excited he showed up all the day
of a big day ed I think in the end of
the season he's gonna grow a penis he is
and he's going to finally have sex with
the enemy so that's our technical term
yeah we're going to use into with the UN
translator yeah that one yeah because
you know they can't just like work they
could make it do like a I hope that be a
scissor yeah a little bit yeah you've
come here to look for the right game
it's just make up a giant out of it a
little bit yeah can you do a lot of
things it's been a really fun really big
comics a lot of writers we got into a
lot of this resin I think you are going
to be really good yeah um that's
discussion on YouTube so whatever was
there anyone who makes predictions are
just predictions anyway they're not know
how many times we right yeah one know if
they just follow what most people would
predict it would be a predictable
showing yeah there's it's far from being
a predictable ship yeah
all right guys yeah after we defend
ourselves subscribe to the real rejects
cook the notification bill follow Stacy
Olivia Howard s Oh Howard 2012 on
Twitter and into the room and checking
around on your miss movies channel Costa
Brienne
yes Sandler and letter videos what do
you want you want some cleavage I could
go for some I think I'll show you how to
tape it ask you all the time because I'm
small justice do you guys fake it I'll
show you to tape it down yeah I'll teach
other soldiers down here for know your
people together to make please
this mission is a whole other tutorial
video is the whole other Beauty YouTube
and bash to black